hi there it's Kevin Van Ord standing in
for reviewer Lafe Johnson to tell you
about the early access version of Daisy
you might think Daisy is about zombies
but in this survival simulation the
emphasis is not on the undead but on
your fellow humans that doesn't mean
that Dom bees don't pose a threat the
first time you spawn into the game you
might be slapped around by a brain eater
fresh out of the loading screen all the
while you'll fiddle with the menus just
trying to figure out how to pull out a
weapon and bash things with Daisy
doesn't just not hold your hand it chops
it right off and throws it to the greedy
undead in this frightening desolate
landscape your goal is simply to stay
alive by scavenging for food and weapons
finding proper shelter and fending off
anyone who threatens your survival if
you played ARMA 2 or the ARMA 2 mod that
spawned this standalone version of dayz
you'll make peace with the unusual
controls quickly and instead let the
perilous world envelop you know music
distracts you from the desolation and
every creak of nearby sheet metal sends
chills up your spine chancing upon a
town can be terrifying for all the
promise in those once cozy homes in
there picketed yards there's a chance
they'll deliver death that you never see
coming
dayz works so well as a survival sim
because it puts few barriers between you
and the world around you
gone are the tidy health and stamina
bars that sneak into the corners of
similar first-person games instead dayz
gnaws at your confidence with little
nags like my stomach grumbles and then
there are the communications you never
want to see such as I can feel warm
blood on my clothes dayz wisely reserves
its menus for essentials like its
inventory which sports a drag-and-drop
option in an improvement over the mod
the inventory itself expands greatly
once you discover pocketed items like
knapsacks and hoodies thus delivering
some of the satisfactions that discovery
of these items would yield in real life
it's the other elements that need work
such as the zombies themselves they
number so few that it's possible to go
half an hour without seeing one and when
you do there's a good chance you'll see
it running through walls or even
vanishing under the terrain zombies tend
to rush you from hundreds of yards away
if they see you and it usually takes a
little more than getting in their line
of sight to draw their attention no
matter how far you might be it's the
other players who instill the most fear
sometimes you'll come across a nice one
and a sense of camaraderie emerges as
you scrounge through buildings and take
out the living undead together most of
the time however others are out to kill
you some play nice at first and then
lead you into ambushes where unseen
snipers shoot you down still others may
trick you into coming near and then try
to bury an axe in your face because they
like the look of the hoodie you're
wearing attempting to hide from and
survive against humans with actual
intelligence elevates Daisy to great
heights of tension and unpredictability
he'll be a weapon all right on don't be
a weapon on the bad guy all right Oh in
spite of this tension Daisy loses its
edge many hours in you learn the tricks
of finding new gear and weapons and you
learn which towns to avoid in which to
ransack each respawn leaves you more
experienced in the stronger and that
confidence encourages board players to
harass newcomers and steal their
precious few valuables by the time
you've put around twenty hours you know
the secrets to crafting and making
infection prone bandages out of old
t-shirts you're a survivor with no job
but to survive in some ways that's the
appeal of the Daisy alpha since there
are no objectives and thus no hope your
only option is to keep surviving until
death inevitably overtakes you of course
this is not a finished game but Daisy is
slowly growing into the space that's
been carved out for it
but given the alphas shaky foundation
and inherent frustrations make sure to
look before you leap
you